you're kidding
i know
how great is that that's unbelievable
are we on a roll or are we on a roll
geez
hey guys pete here let's talk about
better call saul season six episode four
hit and run was a lively one and it's
all fun and games until mike shows up
somewhere out of the blue to tell you
something we definitely shifted away
from the heaviness of episode 3 which
makes sense even if it didn't make for
the most exciting episode of the season
and that is not a knock on first time
director ray seahorn if i hadn't known
who was directing i would have never
guessed that this wasn't done by one of
the series regulars so great job there
604 had some fun some breaking bad
character returns and some main
characters officially meeting for the
first time no lalo but if you're keeping
score gus has a way cooler tunnel under
his house and hey he has a decoy too and
at least one long-running theory can be
put to bed kim will not be getting
hooked on meth and will not transform
into wendy there are transformations
happening though and i'll recap things
and let you know what i think right
after this quick spoiler warning if you
haven't watched better call saul season
6 episode 4 yet then this video won't be
for you and with that out of the way
let's get into it
last week kim advocated for stealing
howard's actual car for their plan and
you saw jimmy getting huel's help to get
inside his car this week we see howard
going to a therapy session and i loved
the touch of him unbuttoning his top
button to get into the spirit of things
after he sits down on the couch we get a
great shot of jimmy approaching the
parking lot in his howard hamlin suit
from the billboard stunt back in season
one and i have to agree with wendy that
his hair looks great the heel device
works jimmy's able to get the car and he
leaves a cone to hold the parking spot
so he can return it and make it look
like nothing happened this is mostly
just fun to watch but you can't miss how
that even though he's stressed that this
whole situation brightens jimmy up in a
way that not much else does kim plays
her part by meeting with cliff maine at
an outdoor cafe you get to see her
attention to detail while she's setting
things up and that she has a little bit
of nerves as she taps her heel under the
table the plan is for jimmy to pick up
wendy at the crossroads motel and make
it look like howard is throwing her out
of his car where cliff can see it while
kim pitches him this idea about starting
a pro bono practice that part all goes
off perfectly minus wendy's root beer
cliff recognizes the car and kim plays
it off and it looks like it all happened
by chance jimmy drives back to return
the car you see him smiling happily
listening to howard's music now which he
turned off when he first jumped in and
then he finds out that someone moved the
cone and took the parking place he does
a quick audible and moves the patient's
only sign over he gets it out just in
time and howard comes back and is none
the wiser and the sign falls over right
after he pulls away so their plan was
good and it worked but as jimmy warned
in the previous episode there were a lot
of ways it could go wrong and despite
all that planning it almost did when kim
brings wendy back to the crossroads they
notice a car pull up across the street
wendy thinks he's undercover cops but
then when kim leaves she sees that it's
following her back at their apartment
jimmy tells kim the story and she tells
him that cliff fell for it that it
worked perfectly she also mentioned that
he liked her idea about what she's
trying to do and would probably help her
make it happen in some way jimmy goes
straight to are we on a roll or are we
on a roll but neither one of them take a
moment to consider their plan against
howard even when kim tells him that she
thinks she's being followed jimmy just
tells her to relax because they're the
only ones who know what they're doing to
me this exchange seems significant and
while her meeting with mike is what
everyone will be talking about there's
some interesting stuff developing here
before that rearranges things here we
see jimmy step up to calm kim's concerns
much like she did for him in the first
couple of episodes last week i said
nacho's situation brought what they were
doing into perspective and hewlett did a
great job of pointing this out but
they're both past the point of being
able to stop and reconsider kim has
evidence that she could probably do what
she wanted to do without forcing the
sandpiper's settlement which jimmy was
always eventually gonna get that money
either way but after the end of last
season their relationship works in a way
that they're way more likely to root
each other on than tell the other
they've gone too far and it's pretty
amazing how he doesn't show up for the
third episode in a row but lala still
manages to dominate the rest of this
episode
in case you've forgotten jimmy mcgill
never woke up one day and decided to be
a friend of the cartel he never intended
to represent lalo that happened when he
was scooped up on the sidewalk by nacho
and he wasn't even allowed to bring his
mint chocolate chip the word that he was
salamanca's guy is out now and it's made
him a pariah at the courthouse but on
the streets he's the lawyer every
criminal wants to have on their side and
it was a little sad seeing jimmy get the
cold shoulder from the beanie baby clerk
and even bill oakley seeing things turn
after all the effort he put in to get
people like hannah banana to like him
but maybe what's more interesting is how
quickly he responds to the attention
coming from spooj and the other
characters waiting for him at the nail
salon i guess we always knew that jimmy
wanted people to like him this was an
important part of who he is but now it's
more clear that he doesn't really care
where that comes from if he's to be an
outcast in legal circles then maybe he
found his people on the other side of
the tracks while he's hijacking misses
in the wind's cucumber water and racking
up a new client list kim is meeting with
her pro bono clients at the el camino
dining room through the window she
notices the car that was following her
pull up across the street and she acts
decisively she just goes over and
approaches it she comes on strong
writing down the license plate and then
asking the driver if they're following
her these are gus and mike's guys
they're professionals they don't give up
any information and eventually leave
when she threatens to call in their
plates as she's finishing up with her
last client we noticed that mike has
made his way inside and is now sitting
at the bar he came in after she spotted
his guys and makes contact when she's
paying her bill he's cordial i would say
almost friendly as far as mike goes and
he tells her that he'll answer any
questions he can he assures her that
they're not cops they're not the fbi and
that he's watching anyone that is
connected to lalo when she brings up the
fact that he's dead he gives her a look
to know that he might not be it's
notable that he refers to jimmy as your
husband rather than saying his name and
it dawns on you later as she's putting
who he is together that he might be
trying to play down how well they know
each other he counsels her to continue
to live her life and ignore his guys if
she sees them and eventually they just
won't be there anymore when she asks why
he's coming to her instead of jimmy he
says he thinks she's made of sterner
stuff this is probably about him seeing
her stand up to lalo in episode 509 and
his other interactions with jimmy after
their trip through the desert obviously
she stepped up to save jimmy in that
interaction with lalo and he was
listening and he watched it all through
his scope as he's leaving she realizes
where she's seen him before he worked at
the courthouse parking lot and as he
acknowledges that and leaves ray seahorn
does this great thing as both an actor
and a director i guess in this case
after she turns back to look terrified
at what she just learned she lets out
her breath it plays like her head was
flooded with thoughts to the point of
forgetting to breathe momentarily so
that when she exhales you're right there
with the character another place where
lalo's presence is being felt even in
his absence is over at gus fring's house
i didn't mention the way that this
episode opened yet the teaser is a
middle-aged couple riding their bikes
through their suburban neighborhood they
stop by a house that's getting painted
and are distressed by the shade of red
that the owner decided to use they don't
seem out of place and are rather
stereotypically what you would expect in
this neighborhood until they walk into
their kitchen and the guys wearing
bulletproof vests there seem invisible
to them next door you see gus come
inside his place he lets his fake smile
fade as soon as he closes the door and
you see that he's wearing a bulletproof
vest and has a gun in an ankle holster
while he's getting changed carrying a
bag of laundry he goes into his basement
and there you see this elaborate tunnel
he has connecting his house to the
neighbors he walks through and passes
his body double his decoy that goes into
his house where we imagine he plays gus
for a few hours and again you see these
neighbors that just go about their
business pretending not to notice
anything he's doing he goes and sees
mike they have a conversation he's a
little upset that the guy that mike put
on the inside's two years at mcdonald's
wasn't enough to get him up to los pollo
standards mike complains about them
being stretched thin they're looking
everywhere for lalo but there's not a
thing that's come up and gus stresses
the idea that lalo salamanca is a lot
and the question remains then where is
he
kim meets jimmy at the location of his
future office we finally arrive at the
strip mall he explains that mrs nguyen
kicked him out and that even though it
sounds like a bad day clients are now
throwing cash retainers at him so this
kind of mirrors that conversation that
they had in the el camino back in the
first episode she had that tough day
with pro bono clients and it was one of
the best of her professional life he had
a tough day at the courthouse but now
he's got all these people coming after
him and he thinks it's great she brings
up the fact that they're there because
of who he represented and he says that's
part of it but he tries to play it down
and besides he needs something right
away he's got a lot of clients and
nowhere to meet them what's more he
thinks he can get it month to month so
even though it's small and it's dirty
and it has a toilet sitting right in the
middle of it it's temporary which we all
know how that's gonna turn out here we
notice that she's now the distracted one
the kim that was gung ho to help craft
saul goodman earlier seems to be in the
background now and she makes the
decision not to tell him about what she
found out about lalo she doesn't try to
dissuade him from taking the office she
says it might be a diamond in the rough
and as they're walking away to get tacos
you see that now it's her who's looking
over her shoulder as the episode comes
to an end
so this was an episode that had the
misfortune of having to follow the final
episode of a major character we didn't
want to see die i think it did a pretty
good job of that not a lot of plot
movement but some interesting character
developments and some really funny
moments to function as a palette
cleanser in between nacho's darkness and
jimmy and kim's impending darkness that
feels even more certain to be ushered in
by lalo salamanca we may not know what
he's been up to since we last saw him
but can all probably agree that it
doesn't involve sitting by idly waiting
for something to happen once this thing
of nacho's death wore off the reality of
how lalo's plans will certainly
overshadow what's going on with kim and
jimmy started to come into focus for me
i think all the breaking bad character
returns and references were fun none of
them distracted from what was going on
and they work to make the shows feel
more connected as we get closer to the
end of the prequel i still want better
call saul to be better call saul not
breaking bad but they do take place in
the same city in the same universe and
they are getting closer together
timeline wise going for tacos at taco
cabeza was a nice jessie and walt
reference that you hear the name you
know you know it and then you remember
that it's from their first junkyard
meeting with tuko and pre-atm machine
spooge is a character that we knew was
one of jimmy's clients so it made sense
for him to show up the strange teaser
leading right into the car theft and
wendy's return was a nice transition at
times i get less interested in this
sociopath version of gus that's
developed over the past few seasons but
thought it was pretty cool to see inside
his house the way that things are set up
it really makes you wonder how or if he
ever unwinds like i know this is his
wartime posture but he has people on the
payroll next door that are woven into
the fabric of the community i did
appreciate the choice to have them go
about their day without acknowledging
what was happening around them it really
added some creepiness to an already odd
couple and gus facing a formidable foe
in lalo in a true life or death
situation and then still being worried
about the workers on the line at los
pollos was hilarious with the changing
of positions that all seemed to further
propel jimmy and kim into their scheming
against howard there's some tension
surrounding them when they were on the
bed talking about how well everything
was working out it felt like the kind of
hubris that comes before a fall jimmy
finding the strip mall office only
leaves the cadillac in francesca before
he'll superficially be saul goodman and
i'm wondering how he's gonna get there
internally kim and mike sharing a scene
was awesome now she has to think about
lalo still being out there and i do
wonder about her keeping that to herself
to protect jimmy i get what mike was
saying and that jimmy is in fact
somewhat broken right now but are they
underestimating him kim is super capable
and smart and they make a great team but
this scamming world is jimmy's domain do
you think that she would have pulled the
sign out of the ground at the parking
lot and pulled that off if someone had
moved her traffic cone plus her
recognizing that this person who saved
jimmy's life in the desert that he used
to work a simple job at the parking lot
has to make her think it all amounts to
me thinking that they're setting things
up to get insane and i like where we're
at and i think that's a good place to
leave things if you want to discuss the
episode in the final season in general
join us for the live stream this week
we're moving it to tuesday night at 9 00
pm eastern so that'll be the same day
i'm uploading this video come and ask
questions there or let me know what you
thought about this episode in the
comments below please like this video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon